okay four people joining this livestream
we are talking about quantum computing
and implementing quantum mechanics and
often language this has been a
long-running series of discussions I
actually think we made off live stream
yesterday we we made some nice progress
on what to do and for the key idea here
is to not try to make everything into a
matrix to instead use the fact that we
are capable of having associations and
deeply nested and sort of sparse
associations instead of trying to
pretend that every combination of you
know every set of product States is
unrolled into a just a straight matrix
and I hope Michael and Jose in
particular may not have heard any of the
stuff I made you mean a density matrix
no I mean I mean structural matrix okay
in our language that's what I mean so
Jonathan did you okay so let's see I
just sent it to you
you
you
you
so should I just run this yep you can do
okay all right what have you call these
things do you call it quantum at'll
should I realize it shouldn't be called
that it should be called quantum vector
I call it quantum system that should do
the same thing okay fine so the idea
here is let me let me go through maybe
this one but then we'll actually do it
over here okay I I realized my claim is
it should be called quantum vector and I
will explain that claim shortly okay let
me just go ahead and say that the
sequel's quantum system for now oh it's
really gonna mess everything up if I
don't do that
okay so we'll use a quantum system okay
so what we claim here is that a quantum
system describes a the basic thing is it
contains a basis it says in this basis
okay so for instance it might say
something like one zero so the basis
might say 1 0 that has amplitude you
know 6 minus I 0 1 spin up or something
has amplitude 7 plus I or something ok
so as soon as we do this hopefully
Jonathan oh wow that's very fancy um
well how do I get out the actual
amplitudes call amplitudes as a property
yes yes this is raw this is a you know
this is a thing that wood could be
written out as 6 minus I over square
root of 87 time you know if we were
writing it out in bra ket type form it
will be this times the bra plus this
comes the kettle's I mean Plus this
times that other cat okay makes sense
so as you assume a pure state that is
correct at the time we are assuming a
pure state dinner age any object for the
name creme system it's two non-stop I
know
I'm suggesting quantum vector and you'll
see why I'm claiming that in a minute
okay but you may also object to but but
I've got reason for claiming that
because I'm also trying to signal the
fact that it's a discrete system um
you know that we're dealing with
discrete quantum mechanics here uh okay
so now the important idea is this idea
of a quantum product did you implement
it with the same name
I used quantum join because I was
sticking with the analogy with lists but
maybe that's wrong
I think it's wrong okay you reek on some
product but okay so let's say quantum
join
there should be a list sorry
that's even more reason to not call it
joy yeah okay
magnificent okay this is where things
start getting interesting so this is now
there is no matrix here there's no
matrix in the sense of you know we could
imagine that there's an eight by eight
matrix okay am I making sense
and yes I'm for them okay but I'm saying
there isn't an 8 by 8 matrix instead I'm
sorry not a length 8 vector sorry that's
what I meant length 8 vector whose
elements are the somehow unraveled
unrolled and re-indexed pieces of this
product States to get what I'm saying
I'm saying we don't do that we just say
the amplitudes are given by this
association where each product state
each basis you know each pilot to these
basis elements gets a certain amplitude
am i making sense it's a different
representation of the same idea right it
is yes but the the very very important
thing is we don't have to hack it with
matrices with vectors and matrices right
but in this case you only have several
of the state so far you haven't yet
created an entangled State
ok all right so now what do we do next
now we have this notion
goodbye yeah go ahead we could use
tensor product of the quantum vectors
and giving another quantum vector that
was my idea that's why I wanted to call
it quantum vector okay and what I mean
is that the function tensor product
could do this and we would have the
nicer person to actually have that be
turns a product exactly and we can we
have the nice representation of its
scaped T product escaped yesterday she
escaped that's cool because it will be
important that we support also the
symbolic cases and we can replace
replace later a symbol by a quantum
vector right okay so it's okay so we've
got this notion of quantum vector here
um we've got this notion of
okay tensor product okay
now Michael okay how do we entangle
ourselves so these are obviously non
entangled states we've also got this
notion um that so we were also inventing
yesterday okay we've got don't do if you
take you feel like the biggest thing is
you don't only have pure states right
the world is made form the entity might
go fine fine fine
so my next the next concept here is this
quantum matrix operator where the notion
would be for example I don't know the
implements at this particular name did
you it's it's quantum operator okay
matrix operator seemed redundant
okay I don't agree with you because I'm
trying to signal the fact that it's
discrete maybe I understand that does it
have string names here yes
I read just has C knots Hadamard and
rotation okay so then the idea would be
that we would give C not of one two for
example and we might apply that to our
friendly quantum AMP quantum vector on
line 41
so right now you can't do it like that
you have to the quantum operator is its
own object and then you then have you
would then have to call quantum map of
that operator onto that vector with the
basis elements one two
okay well we can we can do that quantum
map of the quantum operator of this
right on percent forty four forty one
with elements one two is that correct
yes that should work
it did not
it's argument some right order
yeah that should have let me figure out
what role okay
little bit strange I would also prefer
having the one two part of the orbital I
know that's what I'm proposing okay that
Jonathan has implemented something
different from what we imagined okay
this is what we imagined this is the
operator and this is by default it would
be one two here or whatever however many
arguments the thing has but here you're
specifying effectively how to index into
the basis um the um but could you not
envisage a situation where you would
just want to have you want to specify a
quantum gate without having to say how
it kind of wires into other things to
have just like a standalone and see not
yes yes absolutely so once a matrix
operator of C naught would be a symbolic
thing that hasn't yet been curried
effectively into the right places
right I mean this is some kind of
generalization which I don't yet
understand of currying I claim but it
seems that Jonathan is following this
sub subset map that's what we want to do
that this is a subset map this is the
subset map paradigm that is the operator
form of subset map if I said my analogy
would be that the operator is the
function in subset map so that you
should have a separate quantum map
function which takes ok that's a
different that's a different issue I'm
not sure I agree with that
because I think we can combine those
there's just a string name for something
which is otherwise just a matrix
operation here I mean that's just an
ordinary matrix operation isn't it
I think so yes
um
you
you
okay so okay so now we had one more idea
previously which was this quantum
projection idea
okay and by the way I do notice that
quantum amplitude or quantum vectors
were calling it the thing to notice is
that those things here could be
absolutely anything so for example it we
perfectly reasonable to put in there um
you know a little picture of a spin up
or something that would be a perfectly
reasonable get what I'm saying so that
could be the I don't you know is the
outer list here relevant or not I'm not
sure it is and do you assume they're
also good nor do you allow children
state like no no they're not ones um I
would think that the thing with
orthogonalize itself right because
there's a basis elements on right but if
there are things you don't know what
does it mean for two things to be also
good at that point like you know but up
up eats and down if I will assume
they're orthogonal if you give them as
strings but I agree that you could get
all tangled up that way right okay so
the other concept that we had was this
quantum projection concept which might
be wrong which just says um
that we're basically saying
what are we trying to say we're trying
to say given a basis
what value to extract I mean this is
like a measurement of some kind but
maybe I'm confused here what's that
in my framework it's called quantum
measure if you want to try it okay well
but so okay so this is now on percent 41
for example so we'd say quantum measure
7:41 then what's the what do we give it
and then another quantum system to
project against
okay so if you do percent 41 percent
forty one it should give one for
instance yes right fine um a little bit
objection to this I know what's meant
and it's kind of nice shortcut but the
metro is defined to a complete set of
projectors not a single project or so
there should be at least a list around
one of them right it may and may be
quantum project is a better well that's
why we saw to our quantum projection
here right but but I I mean but this is
okay so Michael I'm already confused now
as I always get confused that's kind of
like that there's basically this this
the human looking it's not trust
basically you measure and you still have
all possible outcomes you already
selected even one that's basically two
steps in one
normally you measure a certain observer
represented to a matrix when you get
with this probability test with this
probability this and then you decide as
a human I'd look at this one and then
you have done the full projection of the
waveform you know that they're kind two
steps I get I get it so we may have to
write that apart okay so where did I
miss
where do we miss on the entanglement
stuff
you go back to your tensor product you
make equivalent of your 38 there's
different also good null vectors and
then add two of them right so Jonathan
and your framework what do we have um
what do we have that does that right now
nothing so in the in the old version
before I updated it today so the in the
old version of the framework we had to
do this sort of thing where you pass
from having a state vector
representations having a date timing and
density matrix representation as soon as
your purity goes below one and then
things get complicated but but again two
steps we could still have a tenured
state that still the vector state and
then the next step would be to have a
journey in density matrix in Tenga
density matrix so look there's there's a
couple of different operations here so I
mean there's the tensor product which is
making a higher dimensionality state
there's also superposition right which
is taking two states I'm a little bit
confused by this I mean and make it you
did in there in the 1d case oh yeah we
already have superposition that that's
already handled
I see so wait wait wait wait wait so the
super position that you would imagine
the way super position works is you
would say if you've got two states and
you want to find the superposition of
them that what you would say is quantum
vector of the Association quantum vector
of blah arrow something rather quantum
vector mu vector of blah arrow something
or other is that what you mean and it
would just sum them I think to do okay
fine that's already handled by the
framework we have yeah well the problem
is what happens when your purity is no
longer what in effect when you can no
longer because right now you know you
can still trace out individual
subsystems in fact I have a function for
doing that it's just quite an extract
what happens when that fails to be the
case then it gets more complicated how
do you create something which is which
has to be represented by a density
matrix you case out Porticus lee okay so
how does tracing out okay so that the
thing that we've got this quantum
projection thing is the way we're doing
it here is not the same that's like a
multiplication of a bra and a cat type
thing the projection thing this is some
of them over mu double vectors not just
one okay but that the tracing out is
what ignoring to do not look at its
object okay but we're trying to get
number of operations so we've got this
notion of a quantum vector you know we
might still want
I think dedicating out most video to
example yeah so if you want to quantum
system or the the the dimension a
quantum system we heard up there if
quantum extract of that and then pass in
the list 1 comma 2 yeah 1 comma 2 for
instance
you
you
you
you
doesn't sue no wait what what's going on
well okay there should be defined oh
wait oh gosh yes sorry I forgot to
define it as a global symbol in the top
of the framework alright anyway that
what that does is it takes out it takes
a partial trace it traces out the third
subsystems you just left with Balaji so
what does it return then another system
and what is that system so is that again
represented we'll wait I don't
understand
this looks like something this isn't a
density matrix representation this is
just a pure you know sort of pure state
combination of basis states right right
so as Michael was saying and there's
really a two-step process here right so
you you would trace it you would do a
partial trace of one subsystem out right
so then you have you have something that
can still be represented as just a state
vector a flat state vector but that
thing is no longer that that's now an
entangled system and so if you now try
to trace out another subsystem you'd get
a density matrix okay what does that
look like how do we represent that
density matrix I don't know I don't know
the product of your states of your
victors okay so let's look at what we
would do that so the density matrix okay
so what you're saying then is that
there's a different thing here so
there's a quantum vector and so in this
way of thinking about it there will be a
so it's only if you like to the commonly
accepted terminology would be state for
both vector and matrix typically the
system is more than that they're real
existing think in the world I understand
that well let's understand what it looks
like so once you what you're saying is
that for the density matrix version
right what you have is every
what do you have you have a typical
density matrix you would have you know
the rows are labeled by two vectors the
victor the basis vectors and the columns
also okay so what you're telling me then
is that let's let's write out the case
we call it quantum state whatever you
call it okay I don't like that because I
really don't like the you know we're
claiming something vastly bigger than we
have there because we've got a discrete
you know we got a discrete thing so
let's let's stick with this for just a
second okay
um and um okay so walk me through what's
in the density matrix here
Michael don't we need some sort of
quantum convector here the empty brass
and catch difference to take their
product yes if you don't have say PT
symmetric random mechanics if we
restrict to ordinary hermitian bonds we
can always canonically identify by that
like we don't have a column and all
vectors in Mathematica so why would we
start having bras and ket's for
hermitian cases fair enough
okay was it only need PT it isn't the
hermitian conjugate business or cpt is
su not a PT issue yes but like the last
20 years have have found Intermatic
increase in interest in PT but in PT
pausing cats are no longer economically
identifiable you can still get real
Ligon values even if your how much like
emission is is it's enough to get the
eigen values but for pasta become sets
of matrices where you can stay that will
absorb this all right so that's a
separate issue
okay Paul Abbott's writing a book on it
oh yeah tall bend or form Imperial some
three sister the main guys wait wait let
me I you know it back in the day you
would always say you know Lagrangian is
this plus hermitian conjugate right
right right
okay and that has nothing to do with you
know CP you know PT and variants cos C
BT no okay so now what but but they're
typically the reasoning is you want your
you want the real eigen values because
your observed things are real that's why
you want hermitian matrices to represent
the Hamiltonians but this is far too
strong as we know today you can still
get sort of you can still get a time
evolution operator that's like even if
it isn't algebraically unitary it's
physically unitary and the same theorem
can still reverse it
that's the idea I see wait a second when
I guess that the question is do we want
our system to be sufficiently general
that we can support well it would be
nice to worry about that but let's let's
worry about other price for this is we
do have to have paws and cats we are no
longer you know this one yeah and what
do we believe physically in this I mean
other than what when does this case come
up other than as a mathematical
amusement it it plays a big hole in the
now so hot tapas or to get into their
business okay um okay well let's let
some boy these fields one doesn't check
in on for 20 years
they mostly don't change but anyway
there unless the whole thing is
revolutionized which this one hasn't
been ok so yet um okay but but so back
to this back to the density matrix
version of this okay so the basic point
is
this really isn't you know the density
matrix is the thing that you get you
know instead of you know is the square
of this creature right that's why it's
not quite there's a star interesting
case the density matrix is if you have
an outer probabilistic effect like 20%
out of probability of this and 30% of
this then it's no longer pure state yeah
I understand how would how do we
represent okay what is your proposal for
how to represent the density matrix okay
so this this one here is a pure state
could be busy like we could skip the
density matrix and have fake random
vector that has as arguments vectors and
probabilities
you
okay so this one here pierced
position these are amplitudes call it
okay so you're proposing that is very
weird
I mean I I do like the fact I don't like
making it what's that this was an trans
day this is all very wheels with
suspended maintaining stuff no no no no
that's not what I'm concerned about I'm
concerned about the the syntactic
structure of this thing being also
probability how do we know if it's a
probability or an amplitude yeah it has
to be right so I mean you know that
right but the fact is that what this is
this is a product of states right
whereas this is I mean this is like
could be trust the state okay so this
one here is a density matrix look the
usual way you get a density matrix is by
you know is it's the it's you know you
get it with the outer product key thing
with the the you know cat bra thing
right this is addendum a so he said this
totally equivalent to effects that
that's the uninteresting case okay well
how do I get this density matrix by
having like okay so let's make a 2d
system with spin up and down so you
either make the superposition of 30
percent up + 50 percent down which is
pure vector state or you have in 30
percent of the cases it's up in seventy
percent it's down now you have identity
matrix but were you talking about no you
haven't distinguish those two things one
of them is an amplitude superposition
collectable exactly to pure states but
is that enough
what about correlations what about day
of diagonal matrix right yes I mean yes
those those aren't probabilities in the
density matrix there's still
they're still complex numbers right in
the density matrix the off-diagonal
elements yes they can be I just try to
describe what's the simplest way that
requires identity matrix no I understand
but what I want to know is what's the
general the dint isn't it the case that
something like this that every one of
these will always be a pair of our am i
confused isn't on the elements of a
density matrix described by pairs of
pure States indexed by pairs of pure
States yes right so in effect we're
taking one additional outer product in
the quantum that exactly right so okay
and then how do you get probabilities
out of all of this then you have to
trace out some things to get
probabilities then you need to make a
measurement all right so let's walk
through the workflow again okay so we've
got our quantum vector we prepared a
state a certain appear certain pure
state for instance okay then we apply
certain you know we can't answer it up
to essentially combine different quantum
you know different quantum systems
together in a tensor product yep without
entanglement okay now we apply certain
quantum operators essentially we apply a
not yet like if you think the views
physical system you prepare it then you
have state evolution and then you have
measurement I don't know what my quantum
operators are here what I mean is I
don't mean measurement operator okay I
mean the evolution operator okay but but
in a quantum you know in a quantum
computing setting that means applying C
knots and things like this right
Hadamard gates so right it means
applying these operations which could
just be pure so so here's a question
presumably
there is the notion of pure time
evolution that's basically a strongly
continuous one power mid or unitary see
macGruber fine but then how does that
actually work so we've got spin up spin
down
you know we've got sort of the you know
some random you know we were the we've
got the time evolution operator applied
to that how will that look in this for
ISM I think the time evolution operator
is just basically a nozzle operator that
gets formed from somebody else it's just
the unitary matrix basically just like
see not as a unitary matrix you're
saying a unitary matrix whose rows and
columns correspond to the basis vector
basis function base sees basis elements
is that right oh maybe it's more helpful
to think of it as a sort of an infinite
family of you know a few three matrices
parameterize by time well okay it
doesn't matter I mean the fact that it
has a parameter is not the point the
point is structurally it's like a
Hadamard gate except that it has an
explicit time parameter in it right yeah
I think so okay okay fair enough down
what's that you might not be able to
write it explicitly down well these are
discrete
some systems yes you might theoretically
be able to fight it down but not
tactically why not
because you would basically have to form
a matrix of a relatively large matrix
potentially fair enough okay so but the
whole point here is that this that
matrix you know ultimately it's an S
matrix like creature that you're trying
to get out it's a it's a well that one
is initial to final States but it's a
unitary time evolution operator that
you're trying to form yeah okay all
right fine okay and then in the end we
want to so it's always sorry for get a
ticket poses poor purposes you want to
be a little bit more general because of
environment it's really not unitary it's
typically only cows like or similar only
what like cows okay are a us basically a
more general form of evolution if if the
system interacts in an uncontrollable
code all of the davis the moment okay
all right okay but but so then okay then
in our workflow we do our quantum
circuit now we're gonna do some
projection slash measurement on that so
far we don't have any in the in the
quantum circuit case we don't have any
mixed states running around yet
everything's a pure state so far right
okay what do you you could feed in a
mixed state all right okay could you now
I don't see why you shouldn't be able to
know I'm not quite sure how practically
to do this because you have basically a
number 1 2 3 4 5 once you have identity
matrix I'm not sure would you given each
port well no no no that's the whole
point the density matrix is telling you
look normally you give a certain
amplitude and in that that amplitude is
an amplitude look look at our case here
right there's an amplitude for this
configuration yes I do
ok so the density mate
is saying we don't know it's saying yeah
you should be able to do this I mean if
it's a finite temperature system or some
such other thing you should be able to
to give it a density matrix and then you
should have evolution for the density
matrix right just like you can have
evolution for the pure quantum state you
have evolution for the density matrix
and it will work the same way I think
yep the only thing that changes is the
or whatever technique you use to extract
things has to fail in the density matrix
case ok but but but the main point is
the evolution operator is applied to
these left hand side state descriptions
and then the thing re jiggers itself
once it has no what way what happens
here so so it the the c not gate applies
itself to that to this thing for example
okay returning a combination of of
multiple ones of these with certain
amplitudes is that correct mm-hmm okay
and then this thing has to unscramble
itself to produce a result that just
says thing goes to amplitude okay so I
claim essentially the same structure is
what would work for the density matrix
yeah okay so I I have to say I think
that this can't be the same object I
think this has to be
the slightly more ornate because I mean
this is otherwise not distinguished from
these product states which are a
completely different thing or
statistical vector
you
maybe I mean I don't know so you're
saying because if the if the ultimate
objective is to have it have the same
you know basic structure as a vector as
a quantum vector but with you know
probabilities instead of amplitudes well
so maybe it's a quantum probability
vector you want to make it explicit that
it's a statistical ensemble but not that
it's a matrix I think
well who says it's a you know the main
thing it's probability is not amplitudes
here right okay but but then okay in the
end at the end of the day we got to be
able to get out these are the
probabilities for these outcomes
right
again how do I go from the quantum
vector to the quantum probability vector
if actually the quantum amplitude vector
to the quantum probability you give it
every absorbability corresponds to a
hermitian operator so you give it this
matrix that represents to absorb of the
UN to metal and then the play ball okay
so but the observable we want to measure
is itself represented is that not
correct that that's like this projection
thing where the observable is
effectively another one of these quantum
practically yeah it no it seemed to
observable is a sum of projections but
there's no some the quantum vector thing
is is it a sum or is it some kind of
Association where each one of those has
a particular alpha okay since it's a sum
of projection operators not sum of
vectors like single spin vus up and down
you can either decide to measure up or
down but you you you measure basically
right and each one has an as a know an
outcome so effectively what you're
saying is i claim i claim that the
answer here is that there's this quantum
projection thing and that what it says
is you have your state here and then
your projection is something like
another state quantum vector arrow up
for example I know the quantum vector
I'm here
yep another quantum vector arrow down so
to my claim would be I might be wrong
but this is that essentially what you're
doing is you're projecting you're saying
you're more less the pure state that
corresponds to up there's the pure state
that corresponds to down yes I'll
project against this and then what do
you get out from so I think and in
general say you measure
the spin in said component so typically
you don't already have a decomposition
in the in the basis but it's it's
equivalent to having a decomposition in
the basis but wait a second so what are
you suggesting the syntax should be what
you have here right now but just a
second one is a propagating matrix this
does it this or is it not this these are
the eigen values or the eigenvectors of
the matrix that that is measured okay so
what are you suggesting that that be in
the other case don't random operate off
well that's a matrix for us that's a
matrix relative to the basis right
that's always saying this matrix
operator yes okay really should be
allowed okay so in it so this you say
can be an operator like you can't have a
measurement device that measures trust
to spin down you measure the spin and
then look how often you go down no I I
understand but this is just a matrix
operating on it's a matrix when the
basis is specified yes
actually in this case hold on a second
hold on hold on hold on you're saying
that the full form of this operator
is actually something it's not a genuine
ordinary matrix it's a thing that has to
say you know up down so you know that
this thing here might be essentially
okay let me be very extreme here sort of
up goes to down
goes to four plus I quit well
because I'm explaining oh I see a zero
matrix yeah yeah I said that has yeah
you know up goes to up these are
components of the matrix now now that's
an alternative to what we've got up
there is whatever the truth P probably
more come up coming down to be mediators
well okay so what we're doing up here is
this quantum probability vector has like
this an alternative form for this oops
that's not what I wanted at all I'm an
alternative form for this would be
something like this
but it is a direction that is not
physical in any sense
fine fine
we could do that no I'm not really that
serious about that
okay so what you're saying down here is
that instead what we should be doing
here is mirroring the quantum
probability vector and doing this it's
that right that D that the structure of
one of our quantum operators appears to
be although I don't understand this
exactly the same as the structure is the
of the quantum probability vector
quantum vector surely not know on some
probability vector that's what Michael
is saying even though the entries can
have complex valleys well no no no look
look that the left hand side is pairs of
quantum vectors right okay that's the
difference right no I am something the
keys themselves are have the same
structure as the keys of the probability
vector but the thing it's said that the
thing on the value side looks more like
an amplitude vector I agree is that
right Michael yes and we need of course
then the diagonal elements yeah well
they're just things where these are
identical right yeah yes okay so that's
matrix operator now but this is relative
to the basis typically we want to
explain I know but these are that's the
basis is right in here right the quantum
vector contains assumed QV stands when M
vector yeah but that's wrong because
that the quantum vector contains the
basis and an amplitude right
whereas what this is is not that it's a
basis element there's what I'm saying
right okay okay fine I understand
oops basis element um so again how is
how is that different from the structure
of the quantum vector because it's pairs
of bases how I'm I don't know it's not
this different is it I think it's
exactly the same that's a product thing
yeah right that's a that's a one level
of tensor product king of the quantum
vector which is another quantum vector
right okay so I agree it has the same
structure okay I thought I was going
crazy
that traditionally the only difference
would be that the first one was dagger
for the matrices and not for their
tensor products of vectors but if we are
saying that we can describe these with
without daggers then this is the same
which has daggers though of this the b
one has a dagger and writes so when we
are dealing with matrices we typically
have linear combinations of things that
are like kit tensor product bra i think
sarah not kid that's a product kit which
is the vector right okay well okay so
there's a issues about hermitian
conjugate
well it's not
not that any more okay okay
okay so again you know at the end of the
day we we want you know we start off
with a pure state let's say we run our
quantum circuit we make a measurement we
want to get probabilities out right
which of these functions is gonna do
that and and the end result that we're
gonna want is something of the form I
would think um you know result arrow
poverty one result arrow property - is
that the same form as some as as random
choice takes let's hope it is
and so that association is just a kind
of mapped form of quantum projection
or generated by an that version of
quanta projection this is or was this is
annoying I I I thought
the Association case of this why doesn't
it even discuss that I thought we made
the Association case of random choice
work in the obvious way can we check
into this I don't know what happened
here
anybody relevant here for this this
thing I can check but I don't think
there's anybody here who can answer that
silly me
you
you
Wow that's the wrong way around wait a
minute what's happening here reverse I
think it's just taking the values I
think it's the wrong way around I mean I
think it should be doing random choice
with the keys right no it's it's it's
following the principle of they take the
values and consider it is a list
I'm not say it's the correct thing but I
think it's I don't think this is right I
mean I don't think it's the right thing
to do here I think there's a bunch of
other functions from nearest onward um
you know
okay well I think that's wrong but I
mean eventually then this is what we
would like to get out presumably unless
we want a thing of the form
- I really don't particularly like
weights arrow choices there right
because then then we would feed this
sent to our like for example categorical
distribution I think okay so this I
believe um Etienne is working on
categorical distribution so I'm saying
because what we would like is something
like that if that's the correct thing
then then we can beautifully do all
kinds of samples we can have you know
means and all that kind of stuff right
that makes sense right because that's
what we eventually want to get out from
our quantum you know instead of getting
the answer seven or something we want to
get out of character categorical
distribution of the results right but
but I feel like we also want directly to
go form a state to state the expectation
value or something like this without
trust having to do the projection we
also have empirical distribution fine
getting the expectation value I mean
Michael if what we ended up having to do
is to write expectation of and then some
whole quantum blah blah blah blah blah I
think that would be quite beautiful I
think so does it what I'm saying you
shouldn't have to go through first
getting the probabilities and then going
up again no III understand well you mean
but concept implementational II I don't
know what happens implementation lis
okay but but conceptually if this
quantum blah blah blah returns crack
Oracle distribution and then expectation
operates on categorical distribution
gives the result 7.2 we're in good shape
why is it not just discrete
distributions i I don't know I thought
it was this I thought I thought this was
the because this has the notion of a
discrete result right it's not one two
three that's the whole point
that will be discrete distribution it's
here you know red green blue each have
probabilities that's a categorical
distribution isn't it I see yeah
actually this expectation here isn't
even right because that there isn't an
expectation if it's red green blue have
certain probabilities the expectation
doesn't have a meaning it's only an
expectation if there's a you know if
there's numbers there right if otherwise
it's red plus a half green and things
see what I'm saying yeah I'm
okay so let's go back to this quantum
projection question okay I'm still a
little confused here so again we want to
get out ultimately this categorical
distribution how do we do that so you're
saying that for this okay
what are the distinct concepts here
we've got this quantum vector we think
we've got a quantum probability vector
which is the mixed state version of that
you know I have to say that if we're
going to do this this way I would have
thought that quantum you know quantum
pure state and quantum mixed state will
be the better names what do you think
doesn't it kind of go against your
emphasize it's discrete velocity which I
don't like well why not vectors your
vector mixed vector but I must say many
people still use to use vector to denote
infinite dimensional vector so this
doesn't footage of the problem easel we
do also have the slight subtlety of do
we want the do we want this thing to
represent a vector or a ray in Hilbert
space I think you mean with respect to
the normalization of things Yeah right
it should be normalized okay so here I
mean look
full version would be pure discrete
state okay
is there any way of making this a single
function you know quantum discrete state
whatever we call it could that be a
single function both the both the
density matrix version and the I mean it
probably could be because I mean we
could certainly have something it just
says pure you know it could be as simple
as just saying pure or mixed here and
then giving the the Association I mean
it's kind of cruddy because what we got
to explain in the structure here explain
to me the difference between a tensor
product of Basie's and what happens in
the mixed state case what is the
correspondence between those two things
I mean I I understand mathematically
it's you know it's precise stops I type
things where it's a product of phases is
to trust a basis it is not yet something
expressed in this basis I can only
explain it using bread spirits but I
think it's no I I understand it in terms
of those I think um well I I'm not keen
on doing this I would prefer to have
something like this quantum district for
example we could have quantum discrete
state and quantum mixed discrete mixed
state I
I just don't want to have a thousand
different um you know symbols around
here right okay so let's imagine we have
these two okay then we understand the
representation one of them is you know
state error amplitude the other is well
I don't understand this again because
this thing here okay so this will
unravel itself to purely be in terms of
basis vectors right I think so right
okay so it's just it's whether you
assign list of basis elements to an
amplitude or a probability I think
that's the only fundamental distinction
I'm sorry whether you as time what wait
you haven't you have a list of basis
elements and the question is only do you
assign is the thing that they're
arrowing an amplitude or a probability
yeah I understand I think that's the
only major distinction well right in the
mixed state case it is a probability yes
that's true right good but okay but then
the actual probabilities of observed
things are the diagonal elements of this
yes just depends what you measure okay
okay all right
so for most
people doing quantum computing they'll
be starting quantum discrete state then
they will be doing some quantum operator
stuff on it where their quantum
operators are represented in terms of
these bases which could be cued it's you
know these are the pieces of a cued it
so our matrix just to be absolutely
clear matrix representation should look
like an alpha product of two I guess
quantum discrete state vectors yes okay
but we might have an el cheapo version
that is a pure matrix right an ordinary
matrix but with that would that be
something that's computed you know
obviously we should have the ability to
call into a matrix representation and
get it out as a standard matrix but
should the internal representation
always be in that form of I don't know I
don't know what I think I mean the way
we can do it is the internal thing once
we can sort the keys then we have a
canonical matrix representation right so
right so right now my the way the
quantum operator works in my framework
is it is it does a key sort and then
represents everything the operator
itself there's just a it's just a matrix
and an indication of the arity
okay
okay
I don't know I don't know that's yeah I
mean we should be able to give it in
this form or give it as a matrix I would
assume yep okay I'm okay but but now
coming back to this projection thing
okay explain to me what this should look
like what is this is this alt is this a
measurement or is this something
different from a measurement yeah
the fundamental operations as far as I
understand it or preparation of a state
unit revolution and measurement correct
everything else call it so but now after
the measurement you just have
probabilities for various things you
measure this component you did you did
not measure this so you measure the
speed and see component you did not
measure this pin see component down this
is what you observed as a result of the
measurement okay well hold on because
because this thing about partial tracers
that's that same third step that's not a
different step for the for the pure
state case yes what so this prepares
state and that state can be you know the
state can be pure or mixed I don't know
how you combine well
creepy or mixed then actually pure mixed
and then there could could make tensor
products of states
so those are the only things you can do
correct
yeah okay unit revolution I think we
understand what that is okay now what
now what are we doing here measure and
absorbable okay
so tell me what the structure of that
operation should be we need to state and
we need the operator that represents two
observables
okay how do we represent that operator
is it similar to this one of these
operators yeah is it yep is it with with
pairs of basis functions yeah okay
I think it's been spinning C's Direction
you measure two things so it's this
little two times two polymatrix yeah
okay so okay okay so you're making the
argument here okay so basic functions
you're saying okay so let's list these
out what we think they are quantum
discrete state quantum discrete mixed
state okay
tensor product okay now for the unitary
evolution you're saying you're proposing
that we essentially have a quantum
operator and that then there's something
that applies the quantum operator that
might be a little bit too restrictive I
really think we should prepare for for
non-unitary things which means during
what you don't have a single operator
you have a list of operators the
so-called cows operators okay fine but
but are you saying that we need a
quantum apply operation
I think so okay that was my whole
rationale for having quantum operator
distinct from quantum map
okay so quantum apply takes a an
operator and lies it to a state okay but
having said which basis things like a 2
3 or something applied to a state right
oh it's we could as well if it was just
the operator without any of this kind of
fancy footwork of selecting those sub
pieces of the state we could just say
operator of state right the reason we
need quantum apply is to is to make that
quantum operator be the quantum operator
doesn't live in the sort of space of the
basis elements it's not my preferred
syntax that's not necessarily how would
you do it I would like the operator is a
certain physical procedure it is not an
abstract C not gate it is a C not gate
between 2 and 3 so the up and the two
ends we have to be cooped okay okay so
you're saying then that this is quantum
operator I'd like to call it quantum
matrix operation or something but anyway
let's not worry about that for a second
quantum operator of the of the pure
matrix here okay then the elements it
applies to and then applied to the state
so in this case it would be yes yeah
what yeah okay yeah yes okay and that
state could be a mixed state as well
right okay all right now finally we have
quantum project or something hard to
read it's quantum project um okay so now
what this what is this look like this
says quantum projection of
something onto a state right okay what
is that something that something is
itself has the form of the first
argument of a quantum operator is that
true if it's a genuine projection then I
think it's a vector yeah I think there
are really two cases here right there's
there's one where you're doing exactly
what our current quantum projection
function does which is just projecting
one vector onto another and then there's
the second case where the instead of
having a vector you have this thing that
has the structure of an outer product of
two quantum vectors and then it's you're
you're doing some kind of maps form of
the quantum projection that's giving you
an association of probabilities exactly
what does this case return what is this
one return that would just give a single
projection what do you mean by a single
projection you mean it's exactly what we
yep no no a real number this is just a
projection of C vectors
it's exactly what quantum measure does
in the framework okay so then this then
if you say what here you have a pair of
these or what you have multiple ones of
these no so you have exactly the same
matrix representation that we invented
before where essentially you know the
thing looks like representation for what
so let you know when we went when we
went through the design of quantum
matrix operator right we had this thing
that looked like an outer product of two
quantum vectors no no no no no no note
here so this thing here the full form of
this is quantum operator of Association
hmm basis one basis to yaro blah blah
blah basis one basis to arrow blah blah
blah right right so that thing has the
structure of a an outer product between
two quantum vectors with just a single
basis state in the key rather than two
basis States in the key what do you mean
a single basis state this thing here by
the way one thing that may get us in
trouble is not distinguishing that in
quantum discreet state okay so in here
the typical form would be basis one
basis two goes to amplitude right right
which means implicitly that list means
those are an outer product state that
that's a product state right right
that's the only point I thought that's
the only point that I was making is that
it looks like it's an outer product of
two things where the keys are of like
he's a lists of length one rather than
of length to see if we really want it to
be precise we would say something like
something like this that will be more
correct because this list actually means
something different right
that would be presumably the true
version of what that left-hand side
really is it's a tensor product of those
basis elements that would work for some
Bolly cases if they are truly vectors
then the multiplication would be
performed yeah well that's horrifying in
its own right okay but but but I mean
okay fine okay so my point is this a bit
of a hack to call the tensor product you
know
it's a slight hack to use lists to
represent tensor products
okay right so the only point I was
making was that then in the case where
you give a quantum projection and the
first argument is one of these things
that looks like it's an outer product of
two quantum vectors then it will do an
out it will do a kind of map to version
of the first case where what you get out
is an association that the science
thinks the probability let's take a look
at this let's take a look at this so
quantum discrete state here has a form
like this okay the tensor product is
technically definitely more correct up
here yeah and it will probably also
better the nest if you do this with it
at times
yeah but as Jose says the tensor product
unfortunately has this nasty feature
that naturally evaluates well it's a
product celebration so it has to will
completely negatives there love well we
could also call that quantum product and
have it be a different thing if it's
only for a presentation we can use
circle times which looks like yeah it's
gonna say that's what we do in the
theorem proving framework or we get one
to have a symbolic operators well I'm
not sure okay I think that will be very
confusing I mean if we if we call it
tensor product here I think it should be
tensor product if we want to avoid
evaluation we just insert inactive
temporarily but it's a horrifying thing
to type well okay fine all right
okay let's not worry about that for a
second I mean I guess that the fully
qualified form internal to this could be
more complicated but it's got to come
out as something right if you ask for
the amplitudes it's got to come out of
something right so we have control on on
when to do their products or for example
we could have quantum vector tensor
product quantum vector and they will
know what to do
that's true yeah that's true
particularly if the quantum discrete
state is formatted in some nice way
right okay
so I agree that the canonical form could
be
you
yeah that's reasonable
okay yeah all right
I mean it's particularly if that formats
as a cat or something that would be cool
and if it can um you're just going to
say this I mean the vector
representation of a basis is in some
sense something like you goo say in the
precision of the presentation in the
abstract is about space you have only a
pawn in a kit so we could have trust bra
of 1 comma 2 comma 3 what would that
mean it is basically bra off and then
basically you flight which basic vector
you have seriously particle system they
are you denote your C basis vector
although it's pot pot ergotism it's day
2 but it gives me three should it be an
a-lister or should it be in a I mean
that's no that's the tensor product of
those things call it okay all right okay
let's keep going down here okay okay
tell me what this should be in in our
new representation down here what should
this be
projection operator I think a projection
operator does exactly what is first line
there shows but there are something more
like you train the measurement that is
more journal it's not a projection okay
so they're basically the first argument
is either a list of this create States
or the corresponding spectrum of the
states over it okay this is a list of
discrete States that's up and down okay
so fine so this is a quantum discrete
state blah blah blah and then the return
from this will be an association right
form actually it won't be it'll be a
categorical distribution because it's
probabilities right of certain you know
QDs wine there's a little bit fun things
like the projection gives you still in
amplitude like things you still have to
square it according to bomb oh yeah I
guess it so this would go oh no wait a
minute
we were saying it could give a thing
like one that's not an amplitude oh it
is an amplitude it could be an amplitude
yeah okay so that that gives an
amplitude number this one is not yet
this is not yet the probability to
observe it as it's clear would of the
probability to observe it I understand
that's the projection onto that so that
is the analog of bra ket you know I
exactly state bra this do we have a way
to write Brown cut yes we'll have bra Oh
okay so it's that case basically where
the state is indicate in the poor is the
QDs at least conventionally you know
okay fine okay so quantum measurement
it's saying these are the states you
want to measure with respect to those
are the those are the pure or mixed
states that you want to measure with
respect to correct yeah and then it
comes out with a distribution which
gives you those those sum those
measurements okay there is of course a
little bit more complicated because this
assumes that all the eigenspaces just
after month dimensions one which was of
course it's not precision reality so you
need actually a ludus projection where
you have only probabilities for subspace
it's not for individual one dimensional
vectors okay hold on let me understand
that so you're saying it could be the
probability that we got out of k0 long
or something which is a superposition of
things is that your point not quite like
like it's a spin see component case we
have two eigenvalues one half I mean
it's one house or minus one house but
for more complicated operators the
subspace associated with a certain hang
wave you can have a dimension larger
than one so it's a subspace it's no
longer just a vector so how would you
represent that here that's why I bring
it up we need a representation for
subspaces I can walk me through this
again so a subspace which is not a
tensor product that true
it'll be Michael a linear combination of
vectors of that subspace did the
subspace is spent by linear combination
of vectors court but it's a subspace
okay hold on tell me tell me how this
works again so you're saying in this
case you're saying I I say I want to
measure with respect to these particular
quantum discreet States but what happens
no once you have discrete States
everything is fine but there are many
observables who is eigen stay all his
eigenvectors are not all one dimensional
okay so you're you're saying sometimes I
want to measure okay so you're saying
the measurement could require a subspace
here for instance yeah okay how would we
represent that what is it it isn't that
just a case of having a list of quantum
discreet States rather than just a
single quantum discrete state we already
got a list of quantum just a nested list
right so you're giving the spanning set
of a subspace and then the categorical
distribution the keys would have yeah I
you can treated in exactly the same way
just having a list rather than a
single-state Michael what do you think
probably yes yet one knows Oh another
case if you think on hydrogen atom to
fully solve the hydrogen atom you have
to diameter simultaneously Hamiltonian
plus square of angular momentum C common
end of angular momentum so in general
you need a complete set of commuting
operators to to boil it down not just
one what's your point that you can't
make I mean did that the case where we
have okay do we have a state and now we
perform a measurement there are various
degrees of generality what this means to
perform this measurement like you can
just measured the Hamiltonian but you
can also measure Hamiltonian and square
of angular momentum at the same time
because they're at the same time sure
but so what I mean so why isn't that -
are you saying that we would get
correlated results for those two correct
there are not kind of one time this they
go together
move these things are measured at once
yeah I understand how does that relate
to the subset no that's that's right
that makes sense but but so now subspace
is related to sense of if you only
measure the amazonian they're not as
clear after angular momentum then
unavoidably the subspaces are
degenerated so the first argument needs
to be a list the first argument has to
be something reasonable ability to
accumulate all cases right but then then
what would happen is in the hydrogen
atom case in the end you get a
categorical distribution of you know
essentially in L in him yeah right you'd
get the the n value we might even have
let's be very extreme n value of one you
know L value I'm let's do value of you
know zero M value of zero
but but that goes to whatever whatever
and this is kind of the form that we
would want it in I would think modulo of
course staring at the NLM are not
immediately if it presented the basis to
tactically but yes those don't form a
basis right they are do cause I mean
this out the eigenvalues but the
corresponding eigenvectors form a basis
okay well that requires a bit of thought
there all right let's unroll for a
second and just see where we're at I
actually think this is pretty good this
is I think I mean I think we've
simplified a bunch of things here I feel
pretty good about it
um so other questions so I mean for
practical things what people do be one
side distances between random states so
we will have function for such things I
suppose we can I mean we can stop
putting them in the function repository
once we put all kinds of random stuff in
there once we've gotten I mean I know
what we I don't know what we're doing
with this whether it's whether it's core
stuff or whether it's in the function
repository do you have an opinion about
that think this is more like a package
so for a moment yeah we just don't I
mean those are I you know it feels they
all go together somehow I agree they go
together but I mean quantum mechanics
has been around for a hundred years it
may be maybe it's time to build it into
the system um we could start
was a package I suppose I don't like it
because I don't even know how we
document it but whatever okay um so well
let's try to actually do this with this
design and see where we get to I mean
this is not really that different from
what we've had before I think it's a
true statement I mean it has some small
syntactic differences but it's pretty
similar to what we had before
yeah this won't take very long gentlemen
um okay so then you know we would we
need one other thing which is the you
know essentially a quantum circuit
visualized
right quantum circuit plot which takes
that combination of quantum operators
the composition of quantum operators
right so it's a qo um at Star qo at star
whatever like that thing and can
visualize that
so make sense to people we didn't dozen
of other functions like a Schmitt
decomposition that people do all the
time all right did we have that already
in the Jacob package and things or not
know what is the Schmitt decomposition
bipartite systems you can always find a
basis so that it becomes a product state
you mean like the organization establish
no do you mean that or you mean
something different but related okay um
okay okay so you're claiming there's a
few other utilities which we need I mean
you know given that we're putting this
in a package I'm you know functions are
cheaper and we might need other
utilities here so I'm a little bit
worried about this basis representation
like if you are what's really called the
computational basis this is all dandy
but if you go to a non-trivial basis
that you express with the first basis
through some operation it becomes pretty
ugly what do you mean is that we need
our function to change basis yeah but
what is the result of changing the basis
that's now this long string so what I
mean so long as the user doesn't see it
I don't why does that matter I mean then
it is at least correct okay
take spin 1/2 particle so we typically
take uptown but also left/right is a
nice basis and expressing left-right
every time so uptown is in coma Hensel
when she just naming I see an ICU so but
if you just named you don't have you
don't have access
what's relation between them they are
not media related they are not
independent they spend the same space ok
let's talk about how we do coordinate
systems like our Theta Phi coordinate
systems because we have a similar su
their Co it yeah so the point there is
the dirt two names the name of the
coordinate system and the name of the
volleyballs
so I think that's what Michael is is
ringing now the fact that we have to
keep we have to carry the name of the
full basis ok how do we do that in
coordinate systems well we have
coordinate chart data and then in the
actual operations we only use the name
of the coordinate system which goes to
coordinate charge data and brings the
information of the actual coordinates
but the coordinate chart data is a
global thing with a particular set of
pre-built charts exactly and knows how
to go from one in charge to another
chart etc so we just have to name for
left ok what that means is we have to be
feeding into all these things like the
quantum discrete state thing a little
bag of information that talks about you
know your basis is really this thing and
then when you change basis a I'm going
to go for a C coming into a Y components
basis well then what would happen is you
would you would refer to your Y
component thing and the first argument
but the second argument would contain
sort of the back trace of what what you
have to do to get from the Y component
thing to something you can actually
compute with
is worth having a separate symbol that's
basically an association that says for
this basis element here's how to
represent it in terms of some other set
of basis elements and then and then
passing that in as within every finite
dimensional state well yeah I mean
that's what we would have is something
like a quantum basis right but that
doesn't need to be any more complicated
than an association right I don't think
so so Bob on our live stream is pointing
out in ket notation you something you
add a subscript to denote the basis
right that'll be a nice typesetting
right yes
okay so then then what we could imagine
here is this thing okay so include eg
quantum basis um typeset as subset of
cat subscript of a cat perhaps and can
we actually do that to use cat and we're
very cool to use cat as their as the
representation of quantum discrete state
as that the typesetting form of quantum
discrete state sounds less seems doable
okay
yes and no I think in general random
disk rate would not be just one kid
would be a sum of kids
sure okay so fine so that that yeah
since one abstract symbolic ket but one
in bases you typically did more than one
yeah I understand I understand so it's
not completely clear how to do that but
I mean this typeset form here seems
unuseful well anyway okay it's something
for now um okay
all right so so among the things that we
need here so we're always going to have
string named standard quantum circuit
operators do we need some standard
measurement operators I already have
some of those I have some sort of Sigma
X Sigma Y it's like measurement operator
things implemented okay okay how about
the quantum circuit plot where are we at
with that Jacob had a version working I
can put it over to my framework
reasonably easily
I think good okay question are these
names right so the only one that seems
very very ponderous I mean quantum
discrete state is pretty ponderous
if in a moment we give up phases
something the discreteness is ganya
that's true Anant Gunnar's is is x
petite right right second argument is
the basis we don't need to say quantum
discrete state we just say quantum state
yeah that's nice and then we can default
to it being a discrete basis I think we
have we had this discussion the other
time and we were thinking that
discreteness does not imply finite
dimensionality and that's why we ended
up with well it could be discrete but
you still have in you can have natural
numbers so that's why the other time we
ended up with quantum finite dimensional
state the correct name yes right well
fine but we can say that but that this
is so then the typical form here will be
a quantum state of blah blah blah comma
quantum basis what since what's the
inside of quantum basis that's the
naming of the basis right and internally
can be represented as an association
that maps from a basis from basis
elements to linear combinations of other
basis elements right ok ok how do we get
this to run on a quantum computer is not
this package that provides computations
from this awesome Mathematica package I
don't know I think I mean honestly I'm
I'm so deeply skeptical about this whole
business um
I mean so what we will have here is
something which computes to run this on
an actual machine we will need something
you know a quantum export or something
that's that's what's called the universe
EQ compiler which goes from a version of
Mathematica implementation of this to
the actual code that the IBM Q owns ok
so it's a quantum evaluate and you
pure states and things and it gives you
you know presumably quantum evaluate
presumably the way it looks
know it you feed it you feed it the
quantum circuit okay so you feed it some
kind of quantum operator combination and
you have to give it an initial state
don't you know this depends on what the
Machine ones mean what the Machine runs
the directive physical realization of
the of the sink in computer I want a
computer I want a factor 15 I mean I've
got to give some initial state to say
what to factor don't die or is all these
quantum operators the things that set
that up somehow that's a good I think
you do need to specify a finite
dimensional state there might be in in
practice for one of these things you
want you will want to say run at a
hundred times and give me the give me
the results right my view would be the
quantum evaluate should just have a
method option that defaults to you know
a local classical simulation where you
can also specify run it on cue yeah but
but but but this notice that this
doesn't give the categorical
distribution this actually gives um
right but as supposing I was saying you
it could return an empirical
distribution oh I see that's the right
thing for it to do you know that's a
good idea right yep that's the right
answer
well there it is
okay now let's see if it actually works
huh see whether the impersonal
distribution agrees with the categorical
distribution um I think we made good
progress here all right let's
wrap it up and this looks rather easy
let's try and get something which we can
ok so somewhat reluctantly I kind of
agree we should just have a package
called quantum
you know yeah I think for the moment is
the best bet
fine okay but then we should have actual
documentation for this yeah um fine fine
excellent all right let's see what
issues come up but then I mean you know
presumably we can implement the sort of
the classic quantum circuits and so on
and just you know watch them go mm-hmm
okay great and so you might want to
somehow incorporate this universal EQ
compile or package which is the absolute
state of the art and the magical package
for factorization oh cool fitting of the
sir code given a unitary matrix
Michael I may need to pester you with
questions about that okay if you could
send it to me that agree up Thanks so I
mean that that one is basically a
quantum circuit from matrix is what
you're saying which which basically
within epsilon because you only have
finally many gate so you cannot
typically exactly realize any any
unitary right this is the question of
what the analog of NAND is effectively
for quantum I mean if you're trying to
reproduce an arbitrary unitary matrix
how do you get that right I get it right
which which is non-trivial no I I know I
thought about this years ago and I was I
was suggested it as a project at the
summer school ages and ages ago to make
this I'm glad somebody's done it good
all right okay let's wrap it up thanks a
lot guys Thanks you soon